[Music]
seeing is believing seeing is the truth
yet cognitive scientists seem to have
uncovered these views as incorrect
eeveelution led us to perceive what is
best for survival and it turns out that
this has little to do with what we call
reality is reality then a creative
construct that helps us to live but
doesn't reflect the world are physical
objects a useful hallucination or is the
very idea of reality perhaps a mistake
and neuroscientists have just got it
wrong so fortunately we have very
illustrious and very real discussants to
help us in this debate we have Donald
Hoffman who is an American cognitive
psychologist at the University of
California Irvine and his forthcoming
book is the case against reality so that
might give you a sense of where he might
lie in this debate Maria Bargh ramyon is
the head of University College Dublin
philosophy department she is an expert
on metaphysical relativism and the
author indeed of relativism and hillary
lawson is a post postmodern philosopher
who calls for a poster ideon return to
metaphysics he's the author of closure a
story of everything and he's also the
director of the Institute of art and
ideas and the question I'll pose is is
reality just a creative construct that
helps us to live but doesn't reflect the
world and I'll start with Donald Hoffman
thank you thank you most of my
colleagues will address this from the
point of view of evolution by natural
selection and the question would be does
evolution favor organisms that see
reality as it is and most of my
colleagues think yes that those of those
creatures that see more truly have a
competitive advantage over those who see
less truly and are thus more likely to
pass on their genes which code for true
perceptions I've been looking at that
problem using the mathematics of
evolutionary game theory which is the
mathematical model of evolution by
natural selection and the answer turns
out to be no
the probability that an organism that
sees reality as it is can out-compete an
organism of equal complexity that sees
none of reality and is just tuned to
Fitness the probability is zero in other
words evolution will drive organisms
that see the truth to extinction if they
compete against organisms that are just
tuned to Fitness so are one of our best
scientific theories evolution by natural
selection gives a very very strong
answer it says the probability is zero
that we're shaped to see the truth and
the question is what are we shaped to
see and I'll propose that this is just a
user interface space and time is our
desktop physical objects are just icons
on the desktop and just like the desktop
on your computer is not there to show
you the truth the diodes and resistors
and circuits and your come inside your
computer it gives you eye candy to let
your control reality even though you
don't know what reality is that's what
evolution did for us it hides the truth
and gives us little symbols that allows
control reality even though we have no
idea what the reality is
thank you great that was very helpful so
on outer mat the same question to
Hillary Lawson Hillary is reality just a
creative construct that helps us to live
but doesn't reflect the world well I'm
I'm a critic of realism not in the sense
that I think there's nothing out there I
there's the stuff out there I just don't
think that it comes already
differentiated and already divided into
objects and things and properties and I
think we we close this what I've
referred to as the openness of the world
we close the openness of the world with
our language and our thoughts so of
course I agree with Donald that we don't
accurately reflect reality I wouldn't
I'm not very comfortable saying that it
reflects it at all the sense the very
idea of reality seems to me to be to
have got oneself into into trouble and
indeed the sort of position
that I take up which I describe as a non
realist position has got a substantial
pedigree you may think it's a seems to
make wacky at first but it's got a
substantial Becker degree in
contemporary philosophy so outside of
analytic philosophy I'd include in that
Nietzsche the later Wittgenstein
Heidegger Derrida they're all non
realists and in some way their response
to that non realism is to avoid talking
about the overall description of what's
going on in the world at all
they have different strategies but in
the end that they're trying to avoid
saying how it Altima is because of a
self referential problem if you're a non
realist how do you actually manage to
say this because the critic will say
well that's just your truth surely
you're just importing truth to that so
I've tried to face that problem and the
framework that I proposed to you that we
think of the world as being open and we
closed it is an attempt to try and
overcome some of those issues of self
reference and at the same time to
provide us with a working model that
will enable us to give a sense to an
understanding of what's going on but
without saying this is ultimately how it
is and just I don't know whether it's
very quickly I could give you an instant
an idea of what sort of thing I want to
say so I want to say there are different
layers of closure in the human organism
we can think of the first glare as being
the sensory layer and the sensory layer
takes all of the stuff out there and it
responds in a sort of particular way so
a neurone in the eye fires or it doesn't
fire so it takes the whole all of the
stuff out there and it has one response
once in a particular response and that's
not a description of what's out there
it's a course or response to what's out
there and and we are able to respond to
that as it were closure in that case
sensory closure and to use it to
intervene but it's not a description of
what is is there and I think we then
have higher levels of
which combined senses from the closures
from one sense with the closures from
another sense and we do that by
realizing the idea of thought so we hold
say the the feel of this object with a
look of it and we hold those two
completely different things with a new
closure which is the idea of you know
the table or whatever we want it to be
so I think this mechanism of closure
enables us to intervene but we don't
know we can't say anything about what
sort of ultimately they're thank you
so Maria I'll turn to you the same
question is really just reparative
constructs which doesn't actually so we
have heard two very heady sexy views
about vision and architecture with the
world I'm here genuinely representing
the common sense view and the position I
have is known variously as common sense
realism direct realism even naive
realism I prefer no realism I think a
new naivete in philosophy is a welcome
thing at this time in our troubled world
so my position basic is but what is the
theory of visual perception for well a
theory of perception has to account for
three things one our connection with the
external world to what goes on inside us
both in terms of our brain and neuronal
activities as well as our
phenomenological experiences of what we
perceive and three and the most
important part for me as far as a theory
of experiences concerned is the
distinction between illusory and
veridical experiences which is basically
the distinction between when we are
right and when we are wrong you can talk
about that in terms of truth or falsity
if you like but some people don't like
that but we do need to make a
distinction between when we get things
right I mean we are wrong and I think a
theory of direct perception to the
effect that when we look at the world
see things that are there and in those
cases or experiences are very Dickel
they are accurate they are truthful or
we get things wrong because of illusion
because of hallucination because of
sheer error and those cases we are just
wrong and we can't have knowledge in
those instances now my direct realism
has a twist to it I'll come back to that
later all right thank you very much and
that seemed Maria you've signaled our
first area of discussion which is to
respond a little to the proposition that
Donald you've be making and then get the
panel's view
so the idea really that you're advancing
if realities are creative constrict them
does that mean that physical objects are
hallucinations I mean Maria's already
distinguished between the ones that are
the hallucinations that are and then
things that aren't actually these
stations are you arguing then that
everything that we think is an object
before us is actually a construction
that's a great question so
you